انتقل موضوع اخر بعد ايام من اعلان المدعي
العام الايراني حل ما يعرف بشرطه الاخلاق
ودوريات الاداب الي بتكون فيها واللي كانت
واحده منها القتل القبض على ماساميني قبل
ما اقتلها في مركز الشرطه وبعد الجدل اللي
صار اصلا حول فعليا حلها من عدمه او جدوى
وجديه الخطبه الخطوه لو صحيحه في فيديو
منتشر على المنصات بشكل كبير وفي تقوم
نساء ايرانيات بالتصدي لنساء شرطه الاخلاق
وبتطردهم من حافله في طاهره خلينا نشوف
نعم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا انتشار المقطع هذا بيجي بعد
ايام بس من تسميه مجله تايم الامريكيين
يعني سائران ابطال العالم
لدورهم او الرائد طبعا في الاحتجاجات في
البلاد هذا غير تسميه المجله اللي تسع
ايرانيات اكثر 100 امراه ملهمه ومؤثره في
العالم ومنهم عدد من النشاطات والمتظاهرات
الايرانيه